Good evening, sir.
Good evening. Good evening.
You able to join, uh, Sunil? What?
Yes, I was able to join. I just
Good evening. Good evening. Anybody
you were able to join early itself?
Yeah, I'm able to join.
Oh, we were not allowed inside.
Okay. Oh,
I don't know what is.
Yeah, maybe they should. Good evening, sir.
Good evening. Good evening all.
Um, So,
so I will download and, uh, share, uh, Sunil.
Yes, sir. Yes, sir. Yes, yes.
Good evening, sir. Good evening. Good evening.
Is my screen shared?
Uh, yes, sir. Sir, it is coming now. Now it shares.
Yeah. So, uh,
I explained about, you know, how the, how
the structure and functioning of human brain
motivated development of a computational model
called neural networks.
Parallel and distributed processing is the concept which is
motivated from the structure
and functioning of the human brain.
And I also explained about
the basic computing element in the case of, uh,
neural networks, as well as this is, again,
borrowed into the deep learning is neuron,
the biological neuron by, based on the description available
for however biological neuron functions
and approximate model has been put
as a computation model on the computing machine.
That's what I, I told last time.
And, uh, now, um,
I think I might have also explained the macle spits model.
Did I explain, uh, some, uh,
anybody can this part I remember.
No, no. Up to neuron and cell, I explained.
Yes. Now, uh, I think a functioning
of neuron also I mentioned no, um,
from a biological neuron point of view, how
that whole activity happens is it's a complex,
um, chemical process.
Once the neuron files,
the transmitter substances are released, um,
into the synaptic junctions.
That's what I told them
and effect of, to riser lower electrical potential
inside the body of the receiving cell.
Uh, essentially suppose if you consider a similar neuron
lying in this neighborhood, okay?
Now, when this fired output is released
as a chemical substance here, that will in turn,
just like not adjust the dendrites
of the neuron in the neighborhood that receives
and which will result in inside
that cell body either increase
or decrease in the potential by a code potential.
That's what is the meaning of, uh, that.
Now, um, the cell body, that is this one,
which I told last time, it acts summing,
summing junction summing device.
Then synaptic junction is the name given to these points,
which are outside the toxin, where these are the points
where the output is released,
and those are called as the synoptic junctions.
Okay? Which is repeatedly, uh, which junction,
which is repeatedly triggered, uh, will grow in stent
otherwise will gradually, uh, weaken.
So accordingly, the strength
of this synaptic junction gets modified continuously.
And, uh, there is something called plasticity.
Plasticity means, no, there's nothing
returning stone and wall.
Stone, no. Uh,
it continuously the synaptic junction strength, uh,
modifies depending on how frequently you're using
or how infrequently you're using.
So based on that, uh, the, uh, no weakening
or strengthening of that connection happens.
And this, the activity at this synaptic junction
that is mimicked as,
and this is the junctions at which the knowledge is stored
in the biological neuron.
So the same thing has been mimicked in the artificial neuron
as what are called is weight parameters.
In increasing large amount of data,
we learn the parameters representing these junction threads.
Okay? So
accordingly, uh, to mimic that on,
as I told know, each neuron, it performs
that simple task you receives end, end inputs, sums them,
compares with the bias.
And once it exits the bias, uh, we say the neuron is fired.
The filed output is a non-linear
output of that some would value, okay?
That some would value itself.
Minus threshold is called as activation value.
That activation value pass it
through a non-linear output function
is the output of the neuro.
If you quickly observe this, no,
the structure in which it is doing, it's just a summation
compared with the threshold, then that value is positive
through a nonlinear output function.
It's a very simple activity compared to, Uh,
a computing processor action.
We are thinking, no, if you take a CPU,
you can implement a very complex, uh,
mathematical function there to execute.
But we are in a neuron.
We are talking about such a simple activity.
Then where is the power for the neural network
or deep learning model is coming.
Again, it is inspired by the structure and organization.
Structure means that organization of the neurons,
so we have several billions of neurons,
they are organized in layers, okay?
And this, the, the, the strength
or the, um, what we call, uh, efficiency
of these neural network
or deep learning models in terms
of modeling the information comes
because of the layered networks
of these neurons in the form of layers.
And several such layers are there.
Then only they become very effective.
Otherwise, if you just take a function
of a simple biological, simple artificial neuron
by itself doesn't have that capability,
but the real strength comes once you make them as layers
of interconnected neurons, which we call it
as neural networks.
So that is what, that is.
The, the real power
of neural networks are deep learning is when you arrange all
of them in the layer, that is
how it is happening in human brain.
Several billions of neurons arranged in layers
that the information flow happens from the base to the, uh,
learning centers in the highest part of the brain.
That's how we are able to do that, And
that motivates the, the organization
of these artificial neurons in the layered manner.
Okay? Um, so
of course there are some aspects called activation
dynamics, synaptic dynamics.
We don't have to bother much,
but if you want, you can, uh, read in the, I know in any
of the a, uh, tool that no activation dynamic means
the activation value of the neuron.
There is a difference between the activation value
and the actual output of the neuron.
The, the activation value is the value in the neuron
before passing through the nonlinear output function.
Once it passes through the nonlinear output function,
the resulting output is the actual output
of the neuron, okay?
And how this activation value
of the different neurons in a given neural network changes
as a function of time.
That is called as activation dynamics.
Similarly, as I told no, the synaptic junction is mimicked
as weights in the neural network,
and you consider all the weights along all the
links of the neural network.
And that how those weight parameters are changing
as a function of time during training, that is called
as synaptic dynamics.
Okay? Um,
and the concept of learning, uh, in case
of neural networks and deep learning is, uh, is the process
of adjusting the weight parameters.
Okay? You incrementally update the
weights, uh, such that no,
as you move from one, uh, iteration to the next iteration,
the weights, uh,
learn more information about the given dataset, okay?
As you move, repeated exposure should increase the knowledge
about those dataset in the weight parameters.
And that is how all the learning laws are learning.
Algorithms are design. That is a basic purpose.
Incrementally adjust the weights, but in what way?
They're just based around that.
The learning law will be different.
The, the working principle of each
of the learning law will be different.
Okay? Um, that is the learning part.
Uh, then, so this picture, which I showed no,
this picture, the basic neuron model picture,
that was the first published model mathematical model
for An artificial neuron.
It is proposed by MAC pit, the scientist.
That's why they're called as MP model
or macx pitch model, where
the neuron activation value is nothing,
but there are m inputs to the
neuron artificial neuron I equal to one to N
multipli W Yeah, yeah.
Is the actual input to each of those M links.
And the link weight is w
and this whole somewhat value minus the theta,
which is the BAAs.
And that value is called as the activation value.
It is a weighted sum of M inputs ai and the bias term theta.
The BAAs is nothing
but from a biological neuron point of view,
the resting potential of the cell body is the bias.
And when the somer value received through the dendrites
exceeds that, uh, bias, then the neuron fights
to mimic that activity.
This bias is there where
you can allow shifting the activation function
by adding a constant to the input.
That is the way we can treat, okay?
Uh, the output value SC is nothing,
but you see exceed the activation value, output value
of the neuron is the FFX.
Typically, this output function will be a nonlinear function
or a binary function.
Simple binary function can be,
we'll discuss about different types
of output functions that are possible.
These people felt, yes, this a good approximation
to implement it on a computer,
but what was missing was, how do I get this?
WI parameters.
See, it's a very simple task, then it's okay,
one time computation, you do it.
But when they are dealing with the neural networks
and deep learning model, when a real data is coming
in a large amount, computing is a challenge.
So that is, sorry, uh, manual calculation is a challenge.
That's where people thought about
can I have a automatic method
for automatically learning these weights?
But that was missing in the case of the basic MP model.
They assumed that you by pen
and paper, your computer is wi, are some statistical method,
your computer wi and inserting those parameters here.
But what people wanted was,
can we directly learn those weight parameters
while training the neuron itself?
So that was one of the breakthrough results proposed
by Pro Rosen Black, which he called it
as a perceptron model, till today, you know,
it's a known neuron model.
Okay? Again, here also the act,
the activation value,
the equation remains same output value.
The equation remains same aim.
Know the difference comes in this error function,
which very, very fundamental to neural networks.
Deep C, you have a target output B,
given from the dataset they know for this set of input
or value, this is the target output.
We are expecting the target output is B Well,
the actual output coming out of the neuron is yes.
Then target output minus the actual
output is the error in delta.
Okay? Where B is the required target output,
you take a consideration where no s the actual output
of the neuron is equal to B, then the error is zero
and the error is zero.
Your weights are exactly reflecting the phenomenon
of the particular process.
On the other hand, if yes is not equal to B,
then there is a non-zero error.
The weight update that is w is given.
What is the next value of WW plus delta W.
That is a change in the weight value that is proportional to
the error that is there between the
actual output and the predicted output or the actual output
and the target output.
That is delta. It is proportional to the delta
times the input
because I'm, I have to, uh, adjust with reference
to the input applied.
That's why, uh, error delta times the AI
and I replace the professional concept with equal,
equal sign, then it becomes eta.
ETA is the learning rate parameters, depending on
what is the value you choose for eta.
Typically people go by know
where the incremental changes 0.001, not 0.01.
Like if you choose very high value 0.1 light thing,
the jump will be high,
but people typically go
through very low shift.
Okay? So essentially the I
to weight, link weight for I equal to one.
Then with W one, W one,
the next instant next change in the value
of W one is W one plus delta W one
where delta W one is E delta,
which another B minus S one, B one minus S one.
That is delta multipli by E one.
That will give me the change in the value.
And so accordingly know, now I'm directly learning the
value of this weight parameters from the error
that is computed.
Okay? And
accordingly know the, the concept
of learning was demonstrated
for the first time in the neural network history.
Okay? And that, that's why this is treated as one
of the breakthrough results in the neural network field.
So introducing learning to the model so
accordingly know you learn the weights
versus fix it weights.
Then of course ology is nothing but know.
How do you connect these, organize these neurons in the form
of layers.
And depending on how the data flow happens,
it can be either feed forward feedback or both.
Combination can be there like that.
So in general, the basic principle
behind learning classes, how do I change that gesture?
There is not much synaptic dynamics as a weight state,
as a function of time in general, without even going
to the details of the learning law
at the current instant of time.
T the weight in the network in a particular link is wi
and I compute the change in the weight
as at this instant of time.
Ts delta, WIT, you add the incremental change
with the actual weight at this point of time
to get the weight in the next instant of time.
That is how incrementally I go on changing the weights.
There are many learning laws,
lab learning, data,
learning lesson based around the working principle.
They're there. But the fundamental principle is this,
under the current instant of time, you have the weight,
you find out the change in the weight at this instant
of time, you add those two to get the incremental
increase weight in the next extent.
Okay? Now we'll go to a simple perceptron learning.
If you recall in the perceptron learning,
delta W is ETA delta ai,
where delta is nothing but B minus S and s itself.
You can take it as F of x.
F of X is this one, this tab that is what is written here.
So delta W code ETA delta A,
and the delta is bi neuron link,
um, neuron link high,
the neuron link, uh,
minus this function F nonlinear function, we are using it
as a sigma signum function.
Signum function is signum of X equal
to plus one if F greater than zero minus one.
If x less than zero
and zero if x equal to zero, that is the val function.
This is a non-linear function, okay?
Even though X is a real value,
the output will be like this either binary or something.
So now what we do is F of X,
the activation values, weighted summation of the weights
multiply with the input vector w transpose, yay,
multiplied by that signal faster
through the signal function.
That will be the actual output of the neuron,
and it is subtracted from the target output
that will gimme the error and multiplied by that vector.
Yay. Okay?
This is for the entire particular neuron
W vector, okay?
The neuron. And whereas if there are m uh,
inputs for the E neuron that WIJ will come where a j
that corresponding dimension I'm keeping, so
the change in the way, it is nothing
but this BI minus E-S-I-A-A-J.
And, uh, if the weights are gesture only,
if the actual output si is incorrect,
that is si is not equal to ba, then it'll be gesture,
otherwise BA minus.
And then, okay,
now we are doing no weight adjustment from the data.
But what, how do you begin with?
That's a weight in the initialization is done
with some random value prior to learning.
Then since the target output is there,
this said supervised learning as it request, desire,
output for each input.
And uh, what has been shown is in certain classes
of problems, the weight will converge to final values
by repeated use of input of typically
that learning rate parameter is set very, very low value.
Okay? So that is about the, you know,
perceptance simple perception learning LA
or discrete perception learning law.
We say there is a continuous perception
learning also, we'll see later.
And this is what is about the perception basic neuron model
and how it is learned.
So any, any doubt here to any of you,
Okay, this perception working maybe, um, um,
sil you may kindly take over.
Yes, sir. Let me stop sharing you.
Yeah.
Alright. Uh, so good evening to all.
So I'll start with the perception learning and, uh,
I'll, I'll take one example to, uh, to make it, uh, um,
clear that how exactly the per perception works, sir,
has given some, uh, uh, like, uh, basic ideas that, okay,
what is the learning law?
So first of all, we'll see the perception, uh,
how exactly it works.
It is the same thing. What, uh, Sara had just explained, uh,
about the, uh, mp, um, case, uh,
um, MP neuron case.
It is in the same way, like this is the neuron.
It looks like where we are doing the weighted some,
and to this particular neuron,
there are some inputs which is coming.
For example, X one, X two, X three are the inputs,
and these three inputs are connected
with the neurons via these weights, W one, W2, and W three.
Okay? So, uh, with, along with these weights, these
inputs or these informations reaches
to this particular neuron.
And here at the neuron, what we do, we do the weighted sum.
WI xxi. So these values, you can take for an example, X one,
0.2, X two, 0.40 X three, 0.6, and W one, W2
and W three are also taken.
These weights I have taken randomly as of now.
Now, once we do the weighted sum,
then whatever is the output from that weighted sum,
we pass it through the activation function.
And here we are using the step function
as an activation function
where if the weighted sum value will be negative,
then the output would be zero.
If it is, uh, weighted sum would be zero
or positive, the output will be one.
Now, that is the case of this stiff function.
So you can see that. So now if we, if we have calculated,
you can see that there, there you can see the calculation
of weighted sum here, WIXI,
and here it is coming as minus 0.38.
If you'll multiply all this. So it, it comes as minus 0.38.
So obviously as per the step function,
it'll give the output at zero.
Now, this is how the single neuron,
or you can say single perceptron works
and just a perceptron working this one, right?
So here, uh, you, you have got some clarity that, okay,
how exactly the, the, uh, uh,
the working happens at the neuron and what, what
and all operations happen at the neuron.
So waited some and activation these two are the,
uh, functionality we have seen.
Now we have, we also talked about the bias,
uh, sometime back.
And, um, you see that, uh, I just, uh,
with the same set of input, X one, X two, X three,
and same set of weights.
So there is nothing, uh, change, which I have done in terms
of the input and the weights.
Same values also have taken like,
like it was there in the previous slide, X one, X two,
X three, W one, W2, W three, right?
The only change. Now you can see that inside the neuron
after the weighted sum, we are adding the bias.
Now, this is what we are the, uh, the change, which,
which I am showing you here
as compared to the previous slide.
Now, with this change, what has happened, the weighted sum,
which is coming as negative minus 0.38,
still it is minus 0.38.
There is no change in the weighted sum,
but as soon we have added the bias
and bias here, it has taken as plus 0.5.
Now, just because we have added the bias, which positive,
now it has become the positive number, right?
0.12. And as per the step function,
if the value is positive, then it'll give the output as one.
Okay? Now, this particular slide is to show
what is the role of bias?
What is the role of bias?
So sometimes what happen that you have the fix input,
no input anyway, you cannot change input is the something
which you have to work with.
And suppose you have decided a set of weights, right?
So with these set of inputs
and these set of weights, we were supposed to get the output
as zero and which we were getting in this particular case,
but sometimes we need some flexibility in this,
uh, in this threshold.
So here, the activation function is working like a threshold
that if it is negative, I'll give zero.
If it is positive, I'll give one.
So it's a very hard threshold, okay?
Which is, which, which we can see in, in, in terms
of this step function or activation function bias.
Help us to, to be little bit flexible
around this threshold.
You can say that bias is something which, uh,
introduces a little bit flexibility.
So what this bias has done here,
it has shifted the decision boundary,
which was exactly at zero.
Okay? So it has shifted the decision boundary.
So it plays around,
so sometimes it can shift the decision boundary
to the right side or to the left side here.
As you can see that minus 0.3, uh, minus 0.38,
hence it was falling here.
So the output was zero.
And just because of the bias, we have moved
to the right side, okay?
And hence, the output is one.
So that is the role of bias,
and it is very important in some cases, going further,
we will understand it here.
It may not make much sense.
That why obviously if you have added plus 0.5,
it has gone to the right side.
How does it make sense? But it is something like, uh,
when we have the fixed set of, uh, fixed threshold,
and if you want to make some flexibility
around the threshold, bias is really helpful.
Bias is really helpful. Okay?
So that's the role of the bias.
So with this, now, what we have understood that along
with the set of input and set of weights
and activation function bias is also one of the, um, one
of the most important components of a particular neurons.
And going further, you will see that mostly in
with all the neural network, what we will build,
we will attach one bias to each neuron,
although it is optional, as you can see
that in the previous case, we did not have the bias.
Still, it worked, right?
Whatever output it give, that doesn't
matter, but then it worked.
So having bias is not compulsory,
but having bias is al always gives us, uh, the, the, um,
flexibility to move around the
whatever activation function we have taken.
So that in that sense, the bias is sometimes helpful to,
to get the output whatever we desire.
So this is one thing about the perception
and how does it work.
Now, uh, now, now, now let's talk about the learning
of this perception, the how exactly the learning happens,
because if it is a machine learning,
and we are already, did you show the demo previous slide?
Uh, oh, yeah, sorry, I have the demo. So I'll just show you.
I'll switch to the demo to show you the same thing
what happened with or without bias.
So I thought that I'll show you the demo.
So here I have this, uh, code written.
It's very simple code,
and I'm going to use the same, uh, uh, uh, like, uh,
libraries and, uh, functions,
which we have already practiced in the last class.
And hopefully you have also done the practice
after I have shared those notebooks with you.
Now, I'm going to use most of the things, uh, similar here.
So first of all, as you can see here, uh, what we had was
this, uh, if you talk about this particular perceptron,
we have the set of inputs as X one, X two, X three,
and set of weights.
And this is what we need to first of all, uh, uh, create.
So I'm using the, I'm using the torch,
and with the torch I'm creating the tensor.
Now, this tensor will represent the set of inputs so
that this is set of inputs, which is being represented by X,
and this is set of weights, okay?
I'm just giving the name it as weights.
So these two are the, uh, tensors. You can say that, right?
And easy to understand it.
Now, because we have done this practice in the last class.
Now, once we have this set of input, set of weights,
then at the neuron, what we are doing,
we are doing the weighted sum.
We are doing the weighted sum.
So if you see this weighted sum operation, it is nothing
but the dot products, right?
It dot products.
0.2 is being multiplied with minus 0.3,
0.4 is being multiplied with 0.4,
and 0.6 is being multiplied
with minus zero point, it says dot product, right?
And the same thing i I have done here is I have taken
this torch.dot.
So the function is already defined in the torch library.
We are utilizing that one
and passing the two tensors, which we want to,
uh, do the dot product.
So w and x, these two are the tensiles,
which we have just created.
We are trying to do the dot product,
and hence this one line will do the dot product, okay?
And here, here we can see that what is the output,
which is coming from the dot product.
Now you can see that it is coming as minus 0.37.
So according to the step function, which says
that returns one, if X is greater than zero,
and what is x, X will be our weighted sum, L zero.
That means that if the X is less than zero
or equal to zero, the output is going to be zero.
Now, this is my step function, which we have defined here.
So this is just a definition of the function,
and we need to call this function a step.
So step function is being called in this particular cell,
and what we are passing in our weighted sum,
which is minus 0.37.
And because it is negative, the output will be zero.
Output will be zero. So this is what I was showing you that,
uh, in the, the first case where the, uh, the weighted sum
followed by the activation function is re
resulting the value zero.
Now, the second case, which I have shown you
with the perceptron, is I have added a bias into it, okay?
So same set of input, 0.2, 0.4, 0.6.
You can see that 0.2, 0.4, same set of input
and same set of bias.
I'll use, I won't change that.
But then what I'm adding is I'm adding a bias.
This is also going to be input for the neuron
and weighted some plus bias.
That is what we are going to compute now.
So this is, first of all, let us run this.
Now we have input bias, value and weights.
Now this, this, all three tensors are ready.
Now, weighted sum plus bias, you can see
that product plus bias will give,
give us the weighted sum plus bias information.
So as you can see that now it is coming as 0.12,
which is a positive number,
which is a positive number, okay?
And once we are passing this positive number
to the step function, it'll result as this particular
function which result as one.
Now this is what I was just explaining in terms of the, uh,
uh, uh, theory.
And, uh, this is the demo for that.
I, this is integrated in this slide also.
You can play around it, but I have taken the same values.
What you can see here,
There is a, I don't know the name, uh, sir, uh, yeah.
Um,
Sir, I had a doubt. Uh,
is it that, uh,
Yeah, Please, full output, which you,
which you're saying be that's
because that's the reason bias is helping
and one is a desirable output.
Uh, I missed something in between, uh, what you said. Oh,
If here we have added the bias
and our output has changed to
One, one, And, uh, are you saying
that one is a desirable output
and zero is not desirable output and biases help?
It, it, it may be the case.
For example, I will talk about the exor gate where, uh,
if it is one, one, the output should be one.
So sometimes, you know, what is your target which you want
to achieve, right?
Okay. So in such case where without bias I was not able
to achieve the target, this bias has helped
me to achieve that one.
So yes, it is a kind of supervised case where you know,
the target, what you have to achieve,
and this bias has helped me to achieve that one.
So bias is also, uh, like a weight, it is going
to be the parameters which we are going to learn, uh, right?
But then, yeah, here the bias I have introduced in a,
in a sense that yes, it is something which is helping us to,
uh, uh, shift
or shift the, uh, you can say decision boundary
or play around this decision boundary, sometimes shifting it
to the right side or left side.
So being a little bit flexible rather than visit. Yeah.
So one more doubt, uh, uh, correct me if I'm wrong, sir,
because in the LA last semester when we are doing this dual
networks, I, uh, I was, I was about to bias, we add
because, uh, once
in backward propagation
and where if the weights become zero, uh,
then the neuron gets dead neuron.
So that's the bias helps us not making it to zero.
Is that right?
I mean, I, that, that, that is also one reason maybe,
but that will see later on here,
we have not introduced the back propagation so far, okay?
Right. But still, there is a, uh, there,
there is a reason why we are adding the bias,
but what you have said has also some significance,
which we'll talk once we'll go into the back
propagation, we'll see that, okay. Significance. Yeah.
Okay. But, uh, just to add, uh, I don't know, 0, 0 3,
James Bond, uh, what's your name?
A sir A, please put T and, uh, tell you what.
Sure, sure. Yes, sir.
So others, because we had a very old CAD movie,
go CAD 9, 9 9 from Dr.
Raj Kumar. That's where, so, uh,
see, uh, the, the, the motivation, how
that bias came was, uh, to mimic the functioning
of the biological neuron.
But of course, after that, I use it for whatever mention.
Okay? And he also mentioned, no, I, I don't know how
to fix that bias initially.
That's where I will set that bias, uh, value, uh,
that node value to be either minus one or plus one.
Okay? Then you run, learn the link.
That also has w not weight parameter.
So essentially it is, uh, to mimic that
the equality sign there, uh, WXI equal to,
okay, to mimic, mimic that we use that.
But of course you can. Now it is an handler.
You can use it for any purpose. Okay?
Thank you, sir. Any other query from
anyone so far? It is clear,
Yes. Uh, sir, I
have it out.
Like, uh, we have written the steps out, like, uh,
whatever is given here in the slide, like this and that,
after that did, but how does it make those, uh,
statements of perception?
Uh, uh, I, I did not get to what, what you said. Mm-hmm.
How, how does all the steps makes it perceptron?
Yeah. Uh, no, see,
perceptron was the name, uh, which was given.
But uh, right now i, we, we are discussing how does
that perception work?
Uh, right, so what I'm explaining right now is the,
the working of a perceptron, and this is how it works.
When the set of inputs
and set of weights are there, then how do we add together,
add bias, and then pass it to the activation function?
This is the general working principle
for any neuron or perceptron.
Yeah,
I asked, I asked this question
because in, in Java, right, we have a concept
of encapsulation where we write all those things,
and that whole entity, like if I have
to make a perception in Java, I will
do everything inside the class.
I will have variables and methods and all the stuff.
But here in Python, like how do I make this kind
of stuff? Is this,
Oh, that is different.
Uh, query what you have asked.
See, uh, here also in Python, we can do that going further.
I'm not going to write that weighted surplus bias, uh,
the way I have shown you in the demo, the function,
and we are going to use the PyTorch, uh, neural network, uh,
like modules where we can directly add that layer
and then it'll do all these things automatically.
But so far we have not, uh, learned about that module.
So I have not, I have explained so similarly in the Java.
So they must have made one class
where they have implemented the same thing,
what we have seen just now.
Yeah. So it, I think it is, if it is the same perception
or in Java, it means something
else, I don't know then, yeah.
Thank you. Okay.
Alright. So, uh, so now, uh, once we have understood that,
okay, this is how the, the, uh, perceptron works.
So the next question, which must be coming in your, uh,
mind is, okay, inputs are fine,
and the output which I have to achieve is also fine,
but how these weights are being decided,
who decides that weight?
Suppose instead of minus 0.3, 0.5,
if I'll take something else
or instead of B equal to 0.5, if I'll take minus 0.5, then,
then again, I'm not going to get the output as one,
which is my desired output.
So how do we decide that, uh, the, the set
of weights and biases?
Now that is very important, and that's
where the learning part come into the picture, right?
You can try with some random set of inputs, uh, sorry,
weights and biases.
It may work, but in most of the cases it'll not, it, uh,
it may not, and you may have to try
with a different combination of weight and bias,
and then it may work, right?
So then that, that itself is called learning.
So what exactly we are doing is now for that one,
I have taken one example to understand that.
So suppose that we have this, this, uh, uh, example
where we have one input as CGPA of a student, another input
as IQ of the student.
And based on these two value, we want
to predict whether the student will be placed or not.
Okay? So it is zero means not placed, one minute placed.
So if you talk about the perceptron,
how the perceptron is going to work is it is like, uh,
the X node, it is a bias here.
X one, X two is the actual input.
X node is going to be bias.
And, uh, w node, X node,
because, uh, that is first input will, uh, from the bias,
which will come to the, uh, perceptron,
and then W one X one plus W2 X two,
the weighted sum, weighted sum.
This is the same weighted sum
and plus bias plus B, what you're seeing is nothing
but this particular part W not X, no,
because this X no is my bias.
It is not the actual input.
You can see that X one, X two is my input.
So perceptron equation will look like this.
So now the question is what should be the correct, uh,
correct value for this?
W no, W one and W2.
If we get these two value, uh, correctly, then it may happen
that I will get the correct output as zero
or one for, for the different data points.
So finding the correct, uh, correct values
for these parameters, W non W one
and W2 is known as learning.
And in the perceptron what happened, uh,
the learning happens, uh, with a trick.
Uh, that's why this, this known as a perceptron trick.
I know that you have gone through this, uh,
machine learning in the previous semester as well
as neural network, uh,
a little bit in the previous semester,
and you know that, okay, there is, uh,
something called back propagation at very high level, uh,
where we update these weights, you can say that, okay,
I'll start with any set of weights
and I'll update that one with, uh, the back propagation.
But the point which I want to make here is when in,
in the case of perceptron then when, when it was proposed,
there was no back propagation algorithm, which was, uh,
it, it was not in place.
So people did not use the back propagation algorithm
to come up with the correct set of this w nor WN W2, okay?
And hence what they did
that did something like that support.
There are three point say that these, this,
this blue point is representing the class zero,
and these two points are representing the class one.
So what they did, they started with any random set of these,
these weights w not say that minus one W one, 0.5,
W2 minus 0.3, say that random set of weights.
And then because these are some values, uh, of these, uh,
then, then obviously it'll give us one,
uh, one straight line.
So you can solve it for X two, uh,
and uh, you will get, you will get the, uh,
you will get the straight line.
So this is X one, X two.
So obviously you will get the straight line.
So say that this straight line is here right now,
this linear line is here right now.
So wherever it is at the first, at the first iteration,
this is the first straight line
or linear line we are getting.
And it may not be the correct obviously,
because we have started with some random weights.
So then what they did support, there are three data
perception trick says
that you choose any data point randomly, okay?
So that I will choose this blue
point randomly, we have to choose.
So we don't have any control.
So this point we may choose or this point we may choose
or this point, any point can be chosen.
So what a point, whatever point you are choosing, you see
that, okay, where is your line and where is the data point?
If the data point is in the correct side of the line,
then there is no change in the line.
When I say no change in the line,
that means no change in these parameters.
If suppose data points is in the wrong side of the line,
what you will do, you will shift the line towards this
data, okay?
Maybe I'll shift the line towards this data so that I,
when I'm shifting the line, that means
that these parameters are changing.
Okay? So how much you're shifting those, that
that much change, you will see in this w not W one
and W2, okay?
And that you will do for a particular point,
hence you will come up with a new line.
And then what you will do, you will do this process again.
You will again choose choose any, any other
or maybe the same random.
So because you have to choose, choose any
point randomly it may happen.
The same point will come again as a random point.
Then again, you will see that, okay, it is in the right side
or left side, or correct side or wrong side.
If it is correct side, there is no change in the line.
If it is the wrong side, change these parameters. Okay?
And you do it, you do it for one time, two times, 10 times,
50 times, a hundred times.
That's all blindly, okay? Blindly.
Uh, so obviously there is a, uh,
update rule which we are going to see next for how
to change these weights.
There is update rule, but the weight will change or not.
It depends on the random points what we are identifying.
So if the random point is the correct side of the line,
there is no change in the random weights,
and if it is a, a wrong side of the line, then you have
to change them that you have to update these weights.
So that's the trick.
So you see that with the, if we do it for number of times,
it may happen after certain number of hydration.
This line will be, this line can,
can come at the appropriate place with
where it can divide the two class of the data.
So if this line will move in this direction, suppose here
if it'll move in this direction,
and if it is, it'll come something like that,
then obviously it is, now it has moved like that
of obvious, right?
So now the, you can say that the blue is in the left side
of the line and two green points
are in the right side of the line.
And this is what we have to achieve.
And this, this, this learning is known
as the perceptron trick, okay?
This learn, because now we have never used any, any, uh, say
that gradient, which we are going
to learn in the back propagation,
but it's still, it may happen that
after some number of, uh,
iteration we are getting our correct line.
Okay? So, uh, this is, this is what, uh,
is there in the perceptron trick.
So, uh, uh, just just to show, give a little more clarity.
So w not X, no, WW one, X one, W2 X two is equal two zero.
This is going to be my decision boundary.
And what we'll do, we'll solve it for X two because, uh,
or X one, whatever it is, doesn't matter.
So given X one, what is X two?
That's why I'm saying that solve it for X two,
you will get an equation because W node, you know,
X no is fixed because it is a bias value.
Uh, but it is, it is, uh, it, it is already given to us.
And, uh, w not W one
and W2 randomly, we have started by minus one, 0.5 and 0.3.
You can always solve it for either X two or X one,
and hence you will get a linear line equation
and that that is how you get a initial line.
And then you update these, uh, update these values
of w non W one, W2,
and see that where the line is going
by randomly choosing a point.
So this is, this learning is known
as perception trick learning.
You can say that. Yeah, yeah.
There is just one question, I guess. Yeah.
Yes, sir. Um, uh, so it is actually reducing, uh,
in other terms, we can say that it is reducing the error
between the original value and predicted value, right? Sir?
Yes, you can say that although I have not
yet introduced the error, but which is going
to come in the next slide,
but uh, yes, you can say that some somehow, uh,
we are trying to do that, yeah.
Yes, thanks. Okay.
Right. So, uh, this is the a
Some more hands are there.
Yeah, please, please, please. Soman. Yeah,
Sir. Um,
can you go back to the previous slide? Yeah.
So you had two inputs here
and, uh, uh, I mean three inputs like zero x one
and X two, um, you're setting weights to like the, the
multiplied weights to zero for the decision boundary.
Is it like, uh, we are expecting that decision boundary
to pass through the origin in the end dimensional space?
Yes, yes. So, uh, it is something like, uh,
you see this step function, you see this step function.
So you, it'll give you some clarity that left side
of this step function is one class,
and right side is in one class.
And you can assume that this, this, this point
where it is zero is your decision boundary, so
that you can decide, okay, one class
or other class you can go.
So it, it's a, it is a sensory where,
where this per ion is working
as a boundary class where we can think like that,
Yes, obviously in the, in this case it is,
it is working like, uh, zero or one, yes, yes.
Okay, thank you sir. Now that is, that is what, that is
what is, that is what we are trying to achieve.
Also, we want to make it as a binary classifier,
this perception right now.
Yeah. Any other question from anyone?
Okay, so, so I guess now you have understood, uh, that
what is this algorithm?
Perceptron trick algorithm.
So you start with any set of weights randomly,
like w not W one, whatever number of inputs you have
for those, you have to initialize the weight,
you initialize it randomly, okay?
Bias value, you can set it to one.
And then this is the, this is what we have to do.
We have to compute the weighted sum, which we have done,
and we can, uh, using the predict, uh, step function, uh,
predict the output using the step function, okay?
Uh, so what we have to do is we have
to randomly choose any point,
and we have to see that, okay, it is in the, uh,
correct site or the wrong site, okay?
Then accordingly, we have to update the weights,
and it says that you update the weight only if
misclassified, and this is the weight update formula.
WI is equal to WI plus eta,
and then there is an error, okay?
There is an error into XI. Okay?
And how do we calculate the error?
Say Y minus y hat,
because step function, suppose it is giving the output as
zero, but actual output is one, suppose.
So then it'll be one minus zero.
That will be the error which has to be inserted here.
If the, the correct output is one and,
and predicted output is also one,
then one minus one will be zero.
In that case, this whole term will be zero,
and you're not doing any change in this particular weight.
So this particular weight update will work only if there is
any error here, otherwise it'll not,
so error may be plus one or it may be minus one, alright?
Right? That the, so in that case, your weight will update,
uh, by increasing some value or decreasing some value,
but if it is the, uh, you are doing the correct prediction,
then there is no change in the weight.
Okay? So this is the weight update, update rule
in the perception trick algorithm.
So this is what we follow
and we, every time we change the weights,
all these weights, right?
And then we try, we come up with a new line and we see,
and then we, then we choose the next random point.
Okay? Next random point, and again, we repeat this process.
So second step is going to repeat
for say you can fix that, okay?
I'll repeat it for a hundred times
and that's all, and then I'll stop.
That can be your, maybe the, the, um, you can say that the
criteria where you can stop.
So, uh, either there should no, uh, no misclassified point
because you're plotting, visualizing, you can say that,
okay, there is no misclassified point,
or you have, uh, raised the maximum number of ion.
These two criteria will take you out of the loop
and you can stop this particular algorithm.
Okay? So, uh, to make it more clear, I have two,
uh, uh, two things.
So first of all, I'll show you the visualization
to understand this one clearly.
So, uh, look at this.
So this particular website will show you the same thing.
So here, uh, number of points are taken at a hundred.
You can see that there are two class, one is blue,
another one is red, okay?
And, uh, same algorithm.
What I have explained to you just now,
you initialize the weights, you initialize the weights, the
all the weights to the zero
while there are misclassification points, suppose.
So what it'll do, it'll randomly choose any point
and shift the line towards it
to make it in the correct site.
Okay? You can say that, okay, this is the side of blue.
This is the side of green, uh, sorry, red.
Then line should be this, this line, which is the, this,
this line should go somewhere here.
Okay? So that blue will be all way, all the blue will be
that side and all the rate will be, uh, below.
So that is the ultimate goal.
So, uh,
but then it may not be true when we'll
start this particular algorithm.
So we'll update the weights
and for updating the weight, this is the formula.
Uh, this is the equation which we have already seen.
So I'll play this one and I'll, you will see that
how this line is going.
So let me just play.
So now see that what is happening, so line is not going, uh,
I mean you can say that one by one.
It, it is going up, down, up, down, anywhere,
up, down, up, down anywhere.
And the piece that why it is happening,
if it is going systematically,
then it would've happened is first the line,
which is here first you can say that the line which is here,
that the next line, I would've chosen here
that the next line I would've chosen
because I'm going towards the actual boundary,
then the line chosen here,
and then I would have ended here, which is the,
maybe the correct decision boundary.
But that is not happening. You have seen, right?
You have seen one once again, I'll show you that one
to give you that understanding.
So I will play it again, uh, pause, uh,
and I will play it again.
Uh, sorry. So reset, okay, reset.
Now say that these two are the
classes, this is the correct decision.
Bond dotted line is showing the correct decision boundary.
And then this is the line which we are starting.
So some set of weights, random set
of weights, we are, which we are starting.
So if I play it now, you see
that this line going very up here also sometime going very
down here also sometime now, see
after how many iteration, 29 iteration,
it has done it for 29 times.
And then it, it would, it has found that, okay,
this is the place where we have the
correct decision boundary.
So what is happening is every time it is choosing
one point randomly.
So the point may be here
or the point may be here,
we don't know the point can be anywhere.
Okay? So the point, if it is choosing here,
the line will go here, so it'll only try
to make this line correct.
Okay, this line should be at the left side
and rest, everything is right, rest,
everything is in the right side.
But if I'm choosing the next line, which I have
to choose randomly, next point, which I have
to choose randomly here, then this line will di from this
place, it'll come directly here
because this, it'll only focus on this particular rate
point, which has to, it has to be
below this particular line.
And that's how it go up and down, up and, and down.
Very, uh, in, in every attrition, change the weights.
But after certain number of times it may converge.
It may converge. That is what,
because you can still see that, that your
data points are linearly acceptable.
You can still see that. So, uh, it, it, it has able
to identify this particular decision bond, right?
Yeah, yeah. Uh, what, what is the query?
Karthik? Karthik is the question.
Karthik. Uh, yes, sir.
So, uh, here the percept, the line says perceptron
as a supervised learning model,
but, uh, we in, uh, we learned that perceptron is the, uh,
base for our deep learning, uh, part.
So, uh, can you just explain more this, how would
I'll explain that how the, uh, uh, the initial perceptron,
which was a single neuron later,
people have extended for deep learning.
So I'll explain that case also that
how we moved from single neuron to the multiple neuron
and from multiple neuron to the multiple layers
and then way forward is the deep learning.
So that also, also really, I'll take you to the direction,
but this is the only case where we have a single neuron.
Yeah. Uh, is it the same thing you're asking that,
how it is the basis for
Yes, yes, sir, yes. I'm asking this,
I, I'll take you through that, uh, journey that
how it had happened, actually, yeah,
Sorry. Uh,
uh, Karthik, can you repeat the question?
I missed the point.
Uh, the, the line over the, the visualization,
which I was saying, the first line says
that perceptrons are supervised learning model.
Uh, the word is, so we have learned in the first MLP class,
perceptrons are the base for deep learning models.
So that's what the curiosity came,
how the perception is the, uh, supervised learning model.
So that basic definition for supervisor learning is, uh,
while whether it is a single neuron or a network
or a deep learning model, while for adjusting the weights,
you have the target output.
In this case, target output is available while love me.
So there's a target output,
and then you compute the value, take the error
between them and adjust. So that's where it happens.
Yes, yes. Okay.
Yeah. Alright.
So any other query at this point from anyone?
So hopefully this visualization must have given you that,
okay, how this perceptron track algorithm works
and see that so far I have done nothing.
No loss has come into the picture
and no back propagation has come into the picture.
That's why the name
of the algorithm is perception trick without doing any
loss calculation and all.
Also, I mean, uh, uh, obviously we are,
we are seeing that, uh, uh, we,
we stop the itration will, uh, means the loop will stop
with a two condition.
Either we have raised the maximum number of itration,
which is set here, uh, which is, uh, set, uh,
might be set here.
I don't know. It, it might be set for the, uh, complete, uh,
uh, means a hundred percent classification.
That that is, that is how,
because it is linearly acceptable line.
But, uh, you can also set it for the number of hydration,
which with, uh, which you want
to run this particular algorithm.
Okay? So I'll switch back
to the other slide.
Yeah. Here, so we were here,
so this is the algorithm which I wanted to explain,
and now I also have the demo for that one.
So let me now show, show you the demo for the same thing.
So, uh,
You can do the practice for this, this demo file, which I,
i, I will share.
So here, uh, let me stop this, to connect this one.
So here I'm just importing some of the files
and, uh, creating the same data
set, which I have shown you there.
That there are two dimensions.
First one is CGPA, another one is IQ only thing is just
to normalize, IQ is divided by 10
because IQ was in 1 10, 1 20, 1 0 5,
which is completely different from the CGPA,
which is 6.5, 7.4.
So just to normalize a little bit, I have divided it by 10.
So that's why it is written in IQ by 10. That is one chain.
So X is this, this is the tensor, okay? Two dimensional.
So there are three rows
and two columns in this tensor three, cross two, the size
of this particular tensor,
and this is the label or the target.
You can say that first one has the label
as zero second data point is labeled as one third is one.
So this is why data, the same data which we have seen there
in the slide, uh, this is just to confirm.
And now what we have done is to our perceptron,
we have added a bias,
but in our input we don't have the bias.
So, but if you see the, this particular, uh, equation,
we always write the decision bond equation lab, W node,
X node plus W one, X one plus W2 X two.
And where this x node is the bias, which is set to one
and w node is the weight with, with
that bias is connected with the neuron.
So that is what I'm trying to do here.
First of all, I'm creating a tensor of one,
okay, tensor tensor of one.
And you can, if you can see that this, this X,
so this is the x, it has the zero.
If you will put zero, uh, then it'll, uh, uh,
it'll, it'll take any, and so this is the zeroth index.
This is the first index. This is third, second index.
So there are three rows. So it has taken the, uh,
zeroth index in this particular row,
and it has gone to the, uh, it, it has seen
that, uh, dimension.
It has seen the dimension, okay?
That, okay, how many, uh, uh, so it has in the times,
that means that what it is trying to do, it has trying
to create, uh, create, create a tensor
vertically, not horizontally, if you will.
If you will write zero,
what it'll do is it'll create a tensor again,
but size three, grow, zero means three, row one
and zero column, three row and zero column.
But what I, I wanted is I wanted
that it should have the three rows,
but one column, uh, okay, but one column.
So that is the shape, which I have given.
So you can see that the new tensor has been created as
three row and single column.
A single column. Why I did like that?
Because bias value is going to be one bias, value is going
to be one, and that one I want to attach
with my initial input.
Then only it'll become, uh, this particular, uh,
W not x no, will be true.
Okay? So
because this x, no, X one, X two is going
to be my first row, second row, third row.
So this x, no x, no is going to be attached in first row,
also second row, also third row also.
So x, no value have taken one
and added to the first row, also second row,
also third row also.
So that is the meaning of this particular line. Okay?
So no, I, here, I have just created
that the tensor is like that.
And now I'm concatenating concatenating, my actual X,
which is this, the actual input
with this particular tensor, okay?
With this tensor, and there is a concatenation operation.
So first I'm placing the bias means this 1, 1, 1,
and then I'm placing the X as it is, okay?
And hence, you can see that, that now my, uh,
two dimensional input has been converted
into three dimensional input.
This is what I wanted because I have to convert it
as X, not, yeah, please.
The, the bias for all the three rows you
Have created, right? One,
yeah, all the three rows, right, because, uh,
because when input will go one by row,
by row to the perceptron,
Okay? No problem.
Okay? Right? Uh, so every row there should be bias. Yeah.
Okay. Uh, if it is not clear, let me just show you
that figure once again.
So if you see this particular figure, what is happening is
X node, X one, X two.
So first time X node, X node is anywhere,
one for all the cases.
First time X one, X two will be 6.1110,
and we do all the calculation.
Next time, X one X two will be 7.212,
and third time X one, X two will be 8.2105.
You see that? So row by row,
we are feeding the input to the perceptron.
And every time I want the bias also to be attached.
And hence 1, 1, 1, I have added one more column
to the left of the CGP.
That's all I have done. So that I will get this equation
and I can set it to zero.
And once I'll set it to zero, I'll get this line. Okay.
So that is what I wanted
and this, this is what, uh, we are doing here.
Okay, done. So the input is ready.
Now, uh, I'm just randomly initializing my weight, okay?
Randomly initializing. So rand,
and this is the, uh,
normal distribution will take zero mean one, uh,
standard deviation and three such weights I have
to initialize because x,
not one weight will be attached X one, X two.
So there are three weights, which I want 0.1.
If you wish, you can write usually the weights value
because random, uh, it's a random value between uh,
minus one to plus one.
So it can take any value, like it can take
five also six also.
So usually we don't take the weights
too high, like five and six.
So I have multiplied it like point, 0.1, okay?
So, and it value, we are going to require
to calculate the loss between the correct output
and the actual output, which will require later, not now.
So this, these are the three set of weights.
We have the input and weights ready,
and hence now we need to do the dot product.
That's all. So here we are going
to do the dot product for that.
There is a one function predict XW will pass,
will perform the dot product, and,
and it'll return one if that is greater than zero
L zero, the same thing.
What I, what we have seen for the,
for the decision boundary,
because at the decision boundaries you equal to zero,
so greater than whatever will get weighted some plus bias.
Uh, if it is greater than zero, then it is plus, uh,
plus uh, one, otherwise it is
zero boundary classification problem.
That is what we are solving here.
So yeah, so this particular function is
to get the decision boundary, which I have showed you how,
how to get into the same equation, minus, uh,
so X two is equal two W minus W,
not plus W one into x divided by W2.
If you see that, uh,
same equation is written here, okay?
So X two is equal two W not uh, uh, minus, uh, W one,
X one divided by W2.
The same equation, the the same equation.
What is written here, same thing.
It, it, it's being implemented.
So with this equation we'll get that same boundary
and this, then
what we are doing is we are just trying to do the plots.
Uh, so I will just run this one.
This you can understand it is not diff difficult.
So epoch, I'm setting at a hundred weight history.
I'm storing because I want to plot that, okay?
Weight history, I want, I'm storing
and epoch in epochs, it'll run for a hundred time.
What you have to do is for i, in the range of length x,
there are three rows.
So every time one, one row is going to come, so I will run
for three times 0, 1 2.
That is the meaning of this inner loop.
And every time X zero will go, means first row
will go in xxi and first target value will go in YI.
That is what, and then we are doing the prediction means XXI
will get multiplied with a W.
You will get the prediction, YIY hat calculate the error,
YI minus Y hat,
and you check if the error is not equal
to zero, then you need to update.
If the error is equal to zero, you don't have
to update the weights and whatever is the weight
after every oc, you can store
where in the weight history to see that, okay?
How those weights are changing.
I will just print that for your see this.
So a hundred times means it'll run.
So first time, this is the weights.
Uh, okay, so we are appending this, this is the weight,
and then second time this weights are changing a little bit.
7, 8, 3 2.
And this weight is not changing this time
and you can say 1.1, 1 1 8.
It has changed to 1.1 8, 1 8,
and next time 0.4093, it has changed.
2.5093.
You see that it is based on what data points just selected.
Randomly my line is being shifted to make it correct
and hence the weight has changed.
A, so that is what is happening here
and it is being, it is, it is happening for a hundred times.
Okay, I'll take your question Brenda, just a second.
Let me finish this. And then, um, what I'm doing is
because I need to plot that how the weights are changing
and due to that weights, how my line decision boundary is,
is looking, this is what I'm doing.
I'm extracting the weight, which was at the first iteration,
so zero, which was at the second iteration
and which was at the last iteration means minus one.
Okay? You understand this one, right?
And that, that that is being saved here
and then this particular box is only to show you
that change the first time.
Suppose these are the three data points we have.
We started line here next time in the next, uh, soon.
Next instead of uh, uh,
so next time in the och number two, we are here.
And last time it is not och 10, uh,
I think in the writing it has some problem.
A hundred iteration we have run.
So it is in the last iteration, you see that.
So only the range, uh,
range why it is changing data points is still, uh,
almost at the same place.
Uh, data point wise there is no change.
Uh, but range wise, uh, there is a change.
Uh, you can see that it goes from six to 10.
So data point looks like that it goes from six to 15.
So data point looks like it goes from six to 16, so
that's why you see some variation in the data,
but data points, data we are not changing.
Data is still same.
Uh, okay, so uh, then
at the last iteration, this is what we are getting.
This is what we are. So yeah, so you can see
that there is a clear decision boundary be separating the
blue at top and uh, the two green point at the P.
And same thing we have shown in the visualization also,
this is just the demo for that.
Okay, let me take the questions now.
Brenda, what is the question?
So can you go to the sixth one? Like for each? For loop?
Oh, for loop, yeah. This one.
Uh, a little bit, yeah, here, uh, just trying
to understand sir, there it is mentioned that, uh, wait,
we'll update, uh, like we are adding the error, right?
It shouldn't it be a subtraction?
Oh, so it depends on this Like W minus error. Yeah,
Uh, it depends on the error.
The sign will change this w plus it is written,
but it suppose error is negative
because see if suppose you are at the right side,
then error will always be
zero and there won't be any change.
Obviously, if suppose you are on the wrong side,
so it may happen that YA zero
and your model is predicting one.
So zero minus one will be minus one.
Mm-hmm. In that case, this error will come minus one.
This sign will be minus one.
If suppose your actual value is one
and you are predicting zero, this model is predicting.
So why minus plus one?
So this will additive,
so this sign will change as per this error.
It'll work for both. Yeah.
Got it, sir? Yes.
Any other query? Uh,
if the solution isation, we are considered hundred.
If it's not, uh, conversed within hundred,
what are the parameters?
Correct? So after a hundred iteration, suppose
I have put 1,000 purposefully I had upset two 20
because I don't know what is the correct number I
before, right?
So then you see that what will happen, uh, so uh,
if I plot that this is what has happened, oh, sorry,
the weights are already tuned, so I have
to run it from again, so I'll run it everything again.
So I'll see that what has happened first Itration,
this is the line, second it, and this is the line.
Third iteration, this is the line,
and you see the weight wise.
What is the change? 0.0 3 9 2 2 1.
Here, there is a change 2, 9, 1
and third weight is also changing here.
Also, there is a change in the weights,
but then still my line is very far from the
actual decision boundary, right?
So this is what, once you get to know that, okay,
whatever number of hippo you have set,
my line is not converging.
You may have to try with the, with the different, uh,
more number of hippo or something else you have to try.
Yeah. This is what is the solution,
Okay?
Okay. That is one way.
And then we can also learning factor. So learning,
Uh, learning rate, right?
Can we change the learning? Yeah.
Yeah, you are allowed to change the learning rate,
but usually we take the learning rate very small so
that wherever we are moving, uh,
we talked about the learning rate in the,
I guess previous class, right?
If we take very high learning in linear regression,
we had talked about it, what will happen if it is
very small or very high?
So there was a convex curve
and uh, we talked with respect to that convex score.
What will happen with that if we
take learning rate very small.
So usually the learning rates are like 0.1, 0.2.
It's a small one. It's not like 0.00001, which is very small
or 10 20 or a hundred very, very high.
Yeah, but it's, uh, you can tune it. No restriction on that.
Yeah.
Yeah. Thank you sir. Yes, Linda?
Quick question for epoc,
it's usually based on our experience, right, sir?
Like, uh, we do a trial
and error method, like which one is suiting
and how there is decreasing, correct?
No certain standards, right?
There is no certain standard
for setting the number of epoc.
Yeah. Okay, Thank you
There. Under what
conditions?
Uh, perceptin, uh, perceptron guarantees to convert, sir.
Uh, that is the next thing which we are going to cover.
So going further, we'll see that, uh, that perceptron
converses, if your data is linearly separable
or sort of linearly separable, okay, linearly separable.
As soon your data will be non-linearly separable
or non-linear perceptron will fail.
Now that is the next thing which we are going to cover.
Yeah, okay,
Fine. So, so
far it is good everyone.
So can you just, uh, drag that horizontal,
that loop results a little
bit right side, sir?
Oh, this one? Yeah, Just I want to see.
So it is adding a hundred iteration, right? Yes.
Hundred third list will be added every time.
That how my, uh, so the last one will have everything.
Okay, so every time that is being added,
Yes.
Yeah, yeah. This actually I wanted to see.
Yeah, thank you, sir.
You'll have the access of this notebook.
You can, uh, work practice this. Yeah.
Okay, sir. Thank you, sir. Yes, sir. One question here.
So here we are providing bi um, bias manually,
but in real time it is, uh, adjusted again,
the data our parameter, right?
So bias value, uh, bias of value,
which is usually set as one just to
get this particular equation.
If it is not set to one, then uh,
you can't write the equation, uh, like that, uh, usually,
so bias value is usually set to one.
Now, this weights obviously we are changing
as we are changing this W one and W2.
So this weight we are changing, obviously,
but bias value, we usually, we don't change,
although you can change, uh,
but uh, usually we don't change. Yeah,
Yeah. Okay.
Yeah. Thank you.
Okay. Alright.
So maybe now, sir, uh, if you're there,
Yeah, I, I'm there.
Um, shall we start this?
Uh, it's nine, six, uh,
Uh, if your people have any other question,
we can start this next.
Otherwise I can introduce also.
Oh, so let, let me all of you have any other question.
Okay, so I think many of you ask this question of
how do you ensure convergence
and those things see so far, uh,
sir talked about a single perceptron
or, uh, no, you can.
How? Um, one thing, uh,
he carefully chose the examples while showing the
demonstration training, and he also mentioned the, uh,
men mentioned the statement that
if the classes are linearly supportable,
linearly supportable, that means to say you are able
to suppose if you take a two dimensional plane server
showing, showing the data points of two classes, linear
is a two dimensional plane is a line.
If you can buy a strike line, if you're able
to separate the data points of the two classes,
then there are the linearly separable classes.
Okay? Of course you can extend it to three dimension,
then line becomes a play and all those things.
So the fundamental assumption they made in the case
of percept is as long as the data points
of different classes are linearly supportable, okay,
then you should be able to handle convergences insured.
There is no doubt about it convergences insured. Okay?
See, alternatively there are, uh, machine learning tasks
in which the, the data points
or different classes may not be linearly separable.
Okay? So under such condition,
how do we, um, um, build
the, um, neural networks which can,
uh, still do our separation supportability
of the data points of the given classes.
So that's where know, for example, uh,
say we have all studied the basic logic gates,
our function logic R function
and function, our function and function.
So similarly, XR function, XR function.
Suppose if you see, if you yourself plot the two table
and see XR
and XR functions, the, uh,
if you take the data point belonging to um,
zero, uh, one output is either zero or one.
In the case of any of this logic function,
suppose if you take zero and one
and try to separate by linear class, you can do it in R
and r and N, but you cannot do it by XR
and X mark that you can, you can try to do that.
If you try to put a straight lane in one side,
there will be zero also one also in the other side,
also zero also, then any number of trials you do,
that gives an example
that when the classes are not linearly separable, so at
that point you will not be,
your perception will not converge.
So for that purpose, okay, um,
um, if they're not linearly,
um, that is their ins, then it'll not lead
to the convergence of perceptin law.
And then
accordingly, no, we say such machine learning task
cannot be represented by a single layer perception.
So, so far SAR talked about only one layer
of perception, maybe either one.
Suppose you need only binary classification.
You can use, uh, one perception in a given layer,
or if you more than one class, you can have a series
of perceptrons in one layer.
And as long as the number of classes are linearly,
you can build a multi-class classifier also
by using multiple, uh, perceptron in a given layer,
but single layer, such single perception,
a single layer perceptron, you will not be able to separate
the classes which are not linearly separate.
So that is where we say representation problem, go
to the next slide as,
um, create slide and just come back once again.
Ah, next. So then,
and those problems are treated as hard problems.
The terminology used in the neur network is such problems
which are not linearly supportable are called
as hard problems.
So then how to deal with those hard problems.
So that is where they came up with the idea
that you have a two layer feed for a neural network.
Okay? So with hard limiting
threshold units in the output layer can solve linear
pattern, pattern classification problem.
Okay? So, uh, it is
no, this can also be called as a single layer perceptron
as there are only one layer of nonlinear units here,
a two layer with hard limiting units, uh,
limit hard limiting threshold units in the output layer can
solve linearly sufferable pattern classification problem.
Okay? So, uh,
I told no there are many problems which are not linear
acceptable and ends, it cannot be represented
by a single layer perceptron.
And those are called as the hard pro perceptron.
Then what they do is now they go for two layer,
uh, perceptron.
If I have a two layer perceptron, then I have
one non-linear output function from the previous layer.
Perceptron another hard limiting output function.
You can have a combination of that output function
to generate an nonlinear, uh, curve,
which can round about the, uh,
decision boundaries need not be linear light.
It can be a current light convex surface.
If the data points are lying in the convex surface, then
with having one more previous layer of perceptron
and passing that data through that previous layer
of perceptron and then combining in the, uh, uh,
one layer perceptron, which you're looking,
then it'll be able to handle at least some, some cases of,
um, linearly inseparable problems.
Okay? That's what we told the output
of the second layer combined forming another layer.
Then any ConX region can be formed by separating surfaces.
It'll create a convex surface, which we can use it
for the separation of the problems.
So that is what is there.
Next slide, uh, Sunil,
and this continues suppose a, a place of linearly
separable, inseparable problems which are non convex.
So in that non convex, again,
this two layer will be not be possible.
We go for three layer, um, problems
that we will see in the next class.
I think these things, I'll explain pictorially,
then we'll go to the next, next slide.
Uh, uh, that's what it continues,
which results into more than two layers of ion.
That's where the multi-layer perception comes into picture.
We will see that when we go to the next session,
next session.
Uh, next slide is, okay,
I think we will first in the next session.
First I'll explain pictorially what are these cases
and then we'll take it there. Yes? Yes,
Sir. One quick
question, sir. Yes.
So it means that as the ity increases, the number
of layer also increases.
No non-linearity, non Non-linearity increases.
The number of layer also increases, sir,
Correct? Correct, correct.
Yes.
'cause yeah, as an increase number, that's correct. Yes.
Thank you. Thank you. Thank you all.
Thank you, sir. Goodnight, sir. Goodnight. Thank you.
Thank you. Thank you, sir.
Work, uh, workbook is shared.
Uh, Yes, sir.
Uh, sir, uh, we'll do it, sir.
Uh, you, you created it immediately. Okay?
That is actually created, okay?
It's, uh, created, created Tke. Yes, sir.
Thank you all. Thank you. Thank you all.
Thank you, sir. Thank you, sir. Thank.